hey everybody welcome back happy new
year to you and welcome to mondays with
monica at 6 39.
all right so people started getting
their 600 stimulus checks over the
weekend did you guys get yours
well for those of you who are struggling
to get by right now uh
you're gonna have to get creative to
really stretch your stimulus right
and i have somebody here to help you
joining me to talk about that is local
life coach and small business consultant
christiane anis and she's also an author
she wrote a book called rich girl code
but don't get it twisted she has a story
for you
it's available on amazon christiane
thank you so much for being here
happy new year to you how's it going
happy new year and thank you for having
me i'm blessed thank you
all right thanks for being here you know
when you talk about somebody like you
who is very
good with money you wrote a book called
rich girl code everybody's like how the
heck is she gonna help me
stretch six hundred dollars but you have
a back story give us a brief synopsis
because
you know being down and out is not
something new to you or foreign to you
no it's not i was a young mother you
know i came from the other side of town
you know
and i was not financially literate i
knew nothing about
credit i knew nothing about money you
know i just knew how to go out there
and work hard and get it all right
definitely understand how to stretch a
dime
yeah absolutely okay let's get into it
we have a full screen you have four tips
for us and i'm gonna call them out and i
want you to explain to our viewers
how this can help them okay the first
one is
you say call a family meeting to discuss
how the funds will be distributed again
this is for the stimulus checks you got
600 is not a lot of money
go for it absolutely you want to call a
family meeting you want to discuss the
priorities if there's any type of debt
is it if there if there's any like
immediate that needs to be paid
try to pay on it if not discuss
ownership
discuss investing discuss ways to make
that
600 stretch it may not seem like a lot
but you definitely can
divide it up and make it a lot you have
to be creative with your
financial sustainability
okay and you talk about investing that's
the second one if i'm watching right now
i'm a single mother two kids i got a car
note i got
rent to pay i got a i got uh uh
insurance on the car
i'm looking at you saying i'm sorry
investing are you nuts i ain't got no
money to vest
to invest
again it comes all down to financial
literacy okay i think oh
we don't have enough money 600 isn't
enough to invest yes it is
there's stocks that's less than a
hundred dollars you know you can go in
there and start your
portfolio start building a portfolio of
sustainability that's the key
word don't look at it as just six
hundred dollars look at it as a seed as
a start
yeah okay and you also say pool the
funds what do you mean by that because
right now
i don't know if i'd be willing to pull
my funds with anybody i got kids to take
care of i got bills to pay
what are you going to bring to the table
for me what do you mean by pull the
funds
well when i talk about pulling the funds
i'm more so speaking of family economics
so if more than one person in the home
is getting the check
come together pull the funds together
that's family economics come together
and see what you guys can do what you
can come up with
and how you can flip that money invest
that money
don't be afraid to ask for help don't be
afraid to come together it's all about
helping one another we can do this
all right and the last one you say
consider ownership ownership of what
was six hundred dollars christiane
600 can definitely help you with
ownership stocks
that's one ownership and land think
about land like landwatch.com
land is very inexpensive you know
especially if you finance it and get
a monthly um bill you know it's not
going to cost that much and the 600
can definitely help you you can find
land for like two thousand dollars a
thousand dollars and if you all pull
together
and put that money together ownership
this is why i wanted to have you on the
show because these are things that most
of us don't think about in fact when i
was
going over this when you and i were
talking i was like okay you got to be
kidding me or you're just kind of crazy
because we can't do a lot with 600 all
right tell us briefly about your your
book rich girl code because it could be
a little deceiving
you know we're not rich girls we're out
here trying to make it what does your
book have that can help our viewers
this book has everything and it's not
just about being financially rich it's
about being spiritually rich it's about
being
you know your mentality has to be rich
it's an all-around
rich thing so when i say rich girl code
yes we talk about money we talk about
generational wealth
but it's it's more than that you can't
be you can't have a blood mentality and
be a rich girl
so we start from the bottom and we help
you build your way up from
generational wealth starting your own
business investing in more
i love that okay and ladies and
gentlemen i promise you i did not do
this when we were putting this segment
together
christiane said she told me this
yesterday she wanted to do something a
little extra
for our viewers so christiane i'll let
you do the honors
yes so the first 50 um callers um
to call me i will be giving you a free
30-minute consultation 30 minutes
to figure out where you are meet you
where you are to help you get to where
you want in me to be and you get a free
copy of rich girl code
i love it the number is 877 right there
277-6819 all right folks once again it
is eight
seven seven two seven seven six eight
one nine
thank you so much i appreciate that i
love the giving spirit because that's
what we need right about now
christian happy new year once again and
thanks for joining us on mondays with
monica
thank you have a blessed day all right
you do as you two as well